would you rather
date a guy that's flat broke
but the hot like the finest man you've
ever seen in your life no or
super rich you never have to pay a bill
again
but no is that toxic but ugly yeah but
ugly like he's shorter than you
kind of overweight
date i know what he's married mary
you're with one guy
i have met the finest man that i will
ever meet and he was a thug and in and
out of jail and a drug dealer and he was
the sexiest man ever in my life and i
would never be with him because
what is he doing with his life nothing
what that drug money looking like happy
medium what's that drug money looking
like
not [ __ ] because he keeps going into
jail and he's gotta pay bail
he's right you're right
he's single an option right
none of the above
literally like i don't know that just
that just sounds like a mess i feel like
you know if i could hold my own and i'm
independent i'm probably gonna go with
the attractive person
um
but like genuinely attractiveness for me
has to be your personality so physically
yeah if you
that's fine you could go you could go
with that like the personality is
included in the attraction yeah because
i was about to say if we're just talking
face like you could be really fine but
an [ __ ] so like it's really not going
to be worth it to me if you broke and
mean like pick a struggle but
okay so you so you would pick hot you
would pick rich
you get to pick one hot
rich
okay that's
[Music]
and what about my kids
generational wealth i can trust that i
can hold it down
like yeah but i don't help him i listen
where it's like
i don't like i personally don't want my
kids to ever have to ask me like can i
do this and i don't want to say no like
can i go to this school can i do this no
like
with the career that i'm going into like
probably like i'm gonna make 150 000 at
the most like yeah personally so it's
like
if i'm really looking at like
the big picture
then i'm gonna go in the long run you
want to be able to help your kids that
makes sense because of my personal
experience yeah okay so so hot rich
but whatever i'm attracted to like no
you're you're attracted to the hot thing
okay
so you
like it's not a thing what's your what's
your degree and i'm just curious
advance
does that does that how much does that
make
you
you can make up to like 50k like even
more like a law it depends on what part
of the events you get into that you can
get to hosting a lot of things marketing
pr so if you're at 50k though that's
like but that's the minimum like there's
a lot you can get up to you can get you
can like there's a lot of people that
make up to 100k like
right
you'd be cool with him being like a
stay-at-home husband to be honest i'm
like a career woman so yeah okay okay so
okay so hot hot
rich for me
if he has
something going for him because
essentially he doesn't not the hot one
if he doesn't honestly i'm gonna keep it
100 with you if he doesn't have nothing
going for him
i wouldn't choose either because i'm not
about to you would be by yourself yeah
i'm not about to be with someone that i
don't find
the highlight of this show no no you
could you could alone you just can't
pick one of them yeah
i wouldn't want to just resort to
being with somebody because they have
money i'm going to have my own i'm going
to work hard for my own and have my own
but i don't want to resort to
struggling with somebody because i
struggled my whole life struggling with
somebody not because they're attractive
well but the the see for me like that
would come at the cost of not having
kids and that like i couldn't i could
not i would i think my like purpose on
this earth is to be a mother someday
so if i didn't get to do like i
i would pick the hot one because i have
like the sexual chemistry of them right
no because i have family money so i
don't need it she said i got many
already not not not now but some did so
like for me like i don't have family
money but like i also like i'm but also
i'm italian i grow up in a culture
that's like pop out as many as you can
yeah and i mean i'm not gonna do that
yeah like if i did i would have probably
three kids by now yeah you're only 22.
but she said by now
hey man when do your parents start yeah
yeah so but like i don't know like i
don't have that to fall back on so if
we're going off with children like i
want to have at least three at least
why you'd pick the rich guy because you
you'd have to afford it yeah because
like i also feel like i have a sense
like i'm such a motherly personality and
just in general like i i've always felt
like part of my purpose on this earth is
to be a mom you know what i'm gonna
switch mine because i just know if the
guy was laying around the house all the
day i would not be attracted to him no
matter what yeah yeah
he is i switched my answer i would take
him
you're still in the same spot shut up
before i say some [ __ ] that i'm gonna
regret oh my gosh
i'll just say like when it comes to the
person being ugly like if that includes
their personality i'm not gonna be able
to withstand that emotionally
but if they have a good personality and
they're ugly man i've been with some
ugly [ __ ] before so
you know it's not going to be that much
of a problem because no matter what like
as soon as i see you're a good person
you have a good heart i'm always going
to be attracted to you yeah exactly
exactly